قالت وكاله رويترز ان ممثلي الادعاء في
سويسرا تلقوا اليوم الجمعه شكاوى جنائيه
ضد رئيس اسرائيل اسحاق هرتسوغ خلال
مشاركته بالمنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في
دافوس وقال مكتب المدع العام السويسري انه
سيتم فحص الشكاوى الجنائيه وفقا للاجراءات
المعتاده واضاف انه سيتواصل مع وزاره
الخارجيه السويسريه بشان حصانه الشخص
المعني كما اكد مكتب المدعي العام
السويسري للجزيره انه يتواصل مع وزاره
الخارجيه وانه سيصدر بيانا بشان الخطوه
التاليه بعد النظر في الشكاوى من جانبها
نقلت تايمز اوف اسرائيل عن مكتب هرتسوغ
انه شارك في المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي
كما هو مخطط
له
ينضم الينا من دافوس مراسل الجزيره عبد
الله الشامي اهلا بك عبد الله لو تضعنا في
اجواء بعد هذه المقررات التي تابعناها من
دافوس نعم حتى هذه اللحظه ما قلناه او ما
علمناه هو ان المدعي العام يدرس الشكاوى
التي قدمت من عده جهات في عده مناطق ضمن
الكانتونات الناطقه بالالمانيه في البلاد
نتحدث عن بيرن العاصمه بالاضافه الى زيورخ
وبازل هذه الشكاوى قدمت في وقت متاخر من
مساء الامس الخميس واعلن عنها مكتب المدعي
العام اليوم تواصلنا مع الناطق باسم مكتب
المدعي العام الذي قال انه يتم صياغه بيان
في هذه الاثناء بشان الموقف القانوني وما
سيتم اتخاذه من اجراءات لم يحدد او لم
تحدد حتى هذه اللحظه ما اذا كانت هناك
اجراء اات استثنائيه ستؤخذ اي بمنع الرئيس
الاسرائيلي من المغادره او حتى طلبه
للمثول امام المدعي العام لكن المكتب قال
انه سينظر في هذه الشكاوى الشكاوى التي
قدمت من مجموعات متعدده مجموعات تسمي
نفسها ناشطون من اجل منع الجرائم ضد
الانسانيه وانها تتهم الرئيس الاسرائيلي
بالمشاركه والتحريض على الاباده الجماعيه
سويسرا كما نعلم لديها سوابق في هذا الامر
في حروب سابقه اما في الحرب الاهليه في
رواندا في 94 او حرب البلقان ايضا في ذات
الفتره حيث قدمت شكاوى تم بناء على اثرها
توقيف اشخاص وتحويلهم
للمحاكم بالطبع هي سابقه من نوعها خصوصا
ان الرئيس الاسرائيلي كان ضيفا لدى
المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي هنا في دافوس
والقى كلمه استمرت لمده ساعه بالامس تحدث
فيه عما قال انه حاجه بلاده للحرب ضد
الارهاب والعمل على منع تكرار ما حدث في
السابع من اكتوبر كما قال وبالتالي لم
نسمع او لم نعلم على الاقل انه كانت هناك
يعني سوابق بايقاف او توجيه شكاوى ضد ضيوف
لهذا المنتدى الذي يعد الابرز سنويا هنا
في سويسرا المدعي العام السويسري يقول ان
هذه الشكاوى اذا ما تم اثبات انها لديها
يعني ارضيه قانونيه سيتم رفع الحصانه عن
الشخص الم دعى عليه وطلب مثوله امام
الجهات القضائيه
بالطبع حتى الان ايضا لا يعلم ما اذا كان
الرئيس الاسرائيلي قد غادر ام مازال
موجودا لكن مكتب المدع العام قال انه
سيخاطب الخارجيه في حينها للتواصل مع
الجهات المعنيه اذا ما تم اثبات او على
الاقل وجود ارضيه
لمنع الشخص من مغادره البلاد بسبب
التفاصيل التي سيمثل امامها امام القضاء
شكرا لك من دافوس مراسل الجزيره عبد الله
الشامي